thank you everyone for checking out this
talk this is Joy work with Buddy Casi
Ravi Kumar and Jelani Nielsen
we study several problems relating to
Counting elements in time windows and
they share the following common
structure
there are n items from 1 to n each item
I is associated with some input x i
which we will discuss in a moment
even these xi's we would like our
algorithm to compute an estimate of some
query q
foreign
now there is also a Time Horizon
parameter t
and in the most basic Cloud listing
problem each x i is a Boolean Vector of
length t
where the JH coordinate denotes whether
item I occurs at time J for example if T
is equals to 5 then this may be our
input
now the query that we want to answer has
two parameters S and F the starting time
and the finishing time
and what we want is the number of items
that occur between Time s and J
for example here if we want s equals to
2N f equals to 3 then it means that we
want to count all the items that occur
in time steps two or three
in this case
the item X1 is counted because it
occurs at time 2. the item 2 is not
counted because it doesn't occur in
either time step and the item end is
counted because it occurs in both time
steps so if they are only these three
elements then the answer to this query
would be two
now we also consider a more General
problem which we call K occurring
elements
the setting uh is similar to before
except that each Vector x i is now not
just a Boolean Vector but each
coordinate can be an arbitrary integer
and the Jet coordinate of x i now
denotes the number of time that item I
occurs at time J
for example again this may be our input
and now the query that we want also has
an additional parameter k
and we want to count the number of items
that occur at least K times
within the time step from s to f
when K is equals to 1 this is equivalent
to the easier Cloud distinct problem
that we already discussed
just to give you an example let's say we
have k equals to 3 here and S equals to
2 when f equals to 3 then again we want
to look at these uh two time steps but
now X1 and X2 occurs only twice in these
two time steps combined so they are not
counted in the final query answer
whereas the last element occur exactly
three times so it is counted in the
final answer so if there are only these
three elements then the final answer
should be one
so those are the type of queries that we
are interested in
but we also want to answer this query
while preserving the data sets privacy
and we are using the notion of
differential privacy
roughly speaking differential privacy
says that
if we take a look at the output of the
algorithm for two neighboring data sets
x and x Prime then the output
distribution should be similar and this
similarity is parameterized by two
parameters Epsilon and Delta for those
of you who haven't seen differential
privacy before Epsilon is the
multiplicative approximation whereas
Delta is the additive term
and Epsilon should be thought of as a
small constant whereas Delta should be
negligible in the data set size
in our setting we would like to not just
answer a single query but we want to
answer a family of queries and we want
these answers to simultaneously be
differentially private
there are three families of queries that
we consider in this world
the first is cumulative queries
these are the set of queries
whose window begin at the very beginning
time step in other words we fix the
starting time s2e1 and let the finishing
time FB arbit Curry
in this example where T is equal to 5
that would then be five cumulative
queries
next we consider the fixed window
queries
in this setting there will be a fixed
window site the Buick given beforehand
and we only consider the windows that
are exactly of size The View
in particular in this example we would
have three queries if the window size
the view is equals to three
finally we consider the family of all
possible queries without any restriction
so we consider all possible S and F so
in this setting there would be T issues
two queries
so we have specified the queries that we
want but one additional thing that we
haven't specified is the notion of
neighboring
in differential privacy neighboring
relationship governs how strict the
Privacy constraint is
recall that we
requires that the output of any two
neighboring data sets be similar
so if we set the neighboring data set to
be more General then this constraint is
more stringent it is harder to satisfy
which means that it gives more privacy
protection but it would be harder to
design an algorithm for
in this work we consider two neighboring
Notions
the first one is the so-called item
level setting
this means that we can make an arbitrary
changes to a single item
for example
in these two data set x and x Prime
shown here we change X2 to X2 Prime
where there are changes in many
coordinates
this is in contrast to the second
neighboring data set which is more
restrictive where we only allow a change
in a single occurring in other words we
only allow an addition or subtraction in
only a single coordinate of a single
item
an example is shown here where X2 and X2
Prime now differs on a single coordinate
by just one
okay
so those are all the possible settings
one last thing we have to discuss is the
accuracy notion
recall that differential privacy only
allows for randomized algorithm so we
cannot hope to be correct 100 of the
time and we have to define a certain
certain notion of utility or error so
that we can discuss the accuracy
in this work we say that our algorithm
achieves an error E if the expected
error of each query is at most e
now there are also other Notions of
errors that have been used in literature
and our results as we will see in a
moment also apply as well but there will
be some change in the polyridemic
factors so we are fixing this notion for
Simplicity and also for consistency with
previous work
all right so with all of those in mind
we can now State our result for
Simplicity of the presentations we will
only focus on the pldp setting where
Delta is equals to zero and we'll assume
certain parameter regimes such as the
Epsilon being constant
so the errors that one can get depends
on the notion of neighboring in DP and
also the type of families of queries
so let us start with the even level DP
setting
in this case the cumulative setting was
actually already studied before by Bowl
lot at Al who gave an algorithm with
error locked to the 1.5 t
they also ask whether it's possible to
get
a poly logarithmic error in the fixed
window setting
and we answer the question by showing
that there is an algorithm with error K
Times log to the 1.5 W and recall again
that W is the window size here
interestingly the cumulative setting
there is no dependency or on K at all on
the error whereas in the fixed window
setting there is this multiplicative K
Factor so one might wonder whether this
is necessary
and we show that indeed uh some
polynomial dependency on K is necessary
uh by showing a lower bound of square
root K that also apply for the
approximate DP case
next for the time window setting we give
an algorithm that has an error K Times
log Cube t and a lower bound of root K
plus log t
for the item level setting interestingly
the ballot and else algorithm translate
naturally here with exactly the same
error
however the nature of the problems
change substantially for the fixed
window and time window setting
in particular for the fixed window
setting we give an upper bound of K
times T over w
note here that the dependency on T is
now polynomial whereas before there was
no dependency on T at all
and we also show that this is necessary
by showing a lower bound of T over W
plus square root k
similarly for the time window setting
before we have an error that depends
only on log cube of T but now we have an
upper bound that is roughly T and we
also show a lower bound of probability
as well
we show that the problem become much
harder here in the item level setting
so those are roughly the high level
overview of our result
we'll next move on to how we prove these
results
and for this we will just focus mainly
on the event level setting
and not only that to make it even
simpler we'll focus on only k equals to
one case or the cow distinct problem
so our technical contributions here are
that we show that these cumulative
queries fix window queries and time
window queries are equivalent to
different version of the range query
problem which we'll discuss next
once we show this we can use
known upper and lower bounds from the
literature on differentially private
range query to get our desired results
in particular for cumulative
setting we view the bowl lot and else
algorithm as showing the equivalent
between this setting and the range query
problem on a domain of size t
a fixed window we give a new reduction
that show the equivalent to the setting
where the domain has size The View
and finally for time window we show that
it is equivalent to
a two-dimensional version of the range
query problem
today I will focus only on the first two
results which are based on the
one-dimensional Range query problem
so with that in mind let us recall the
range query problem in one dimension
here there is a domain size d
and the input Y is a vector of length D
where each coordinate is an integer
a range query is a query of the form
asking for the sum from y s to YF where
again S and F are the starting and
finishing point
here we want differential privacy and
the differential privacy is under the
neighboring notion where Y and I Y Prime
are neighbors if they differ on a single
coordinate by a value of one
for this problem uh there are several
known mechanisms the most well-known one
is perhaps the binary tree mechanism
the binary tree mechanism works as
follows
as it name suggests we view a binary
tree on the D coordinates
we then fill in the value of each node
by the sum of all the leaves that are
below it
now this wouldn't be DP yet because we
compute the values deterministically
from the input so we have to add some
LaPlace noise to each node to make it
differentially private
if we scale the lapas noise
appropriately then we can get the
Epsilon DP as we decide
so after adding noise and Computing this
differentially private data structure
how do we answer a range query
we answer it by summing up the
appropriate nodes
in particular we try to sum up as few
nodes as possible
for example if the range query is asking
for
the sum of y1 to y7 then we can take
only the three nodes here and get the
answer
the point is that we only have to sum up
at most log D of the nodes to get our
result so we are only adding up log D of
the noise terms
furthermore each Leaf affects only at
most log B nodes in the tree so the
scale of the LaPlace noise that we need
to add is at most log d
combining these two facts we can
conclude that the error here is at most
log B to the 1.5 over Epsilon
okay so that's the range query problem
and the known algorithm here let us get
back to our Cloud listing problem
we will now show the reduction from
cloud listing to range query and we'll
start with the cumulative setting and
recall again that this is the algorithm
of Bullard and L but we are writing it
in this reduction form
so what do we want we want to reduce cow
this thing to range query
so we start with the X1 to xn which are
the input to call this thing and we want
to
compute and output y to range query
what are the properties that we need for
this reduction to be valid so we need
two properties
first is the correctness we want to be
able to answer each cumulative Cloud
listing on
the X input using some range query on y
furthermore we also need this neighbor
preserving property
for differential privacy
this means that if x and x Prime are
neighbors in X and we feed it through
this reduction we want the resulting Y
and Y Prime to also be neighbors
and we can also relax this a little bit
to allow Y and Y Prime to be a constant
distance neighbor this only blow up the
Epsilon parameter by a constant and so
the error is still the same
asymptotically
okay so with this goes in mind let us
try to do this reduction
so perhaps the simplest attempt here is
to let y to be the sum of X1 to xn so we
just copy the X1 to X and over and sum
them up and get y
so this doesn't work
and some of you might have already
noticed it
and this is because there is a double
counting problem
for example let's say we want a
cumulative query from one to three
then here if we try to use the range
query from one to three to answer this
cumulative query
then we would be double counting this uh
n element
since it appeared in board the second
and the third time step whereas in call
this thing we want to count it only once
so how do we solve this problem
instead of copying each x i over
we create a vector we I where the jet
coordinate of VI is one even only if the
time step J is the first time step that
item I occurs for example here item 1
and item in occur For the First Time In
Time step two and this is the reason why
v i and VN have their second coordinate
being one and the remaining coordinates
being zero
and the Y is defined again as the sum of
the V I's
now the correctness is not hard to see
because we are now counting each element
only once instead of double counting as
before
in terms of the neighboring relationship
if we have x i and x i Prime being
neighbor
notice that the v i
has at most one coordinate being one so
changing from x i to x i Prime will
affect Y in at most two coordinates so Y
and Y Prime will remain a constant list
and neighbors so this is also 5. so this
concludes the high level overview of the
reduction from bolot it l
and we note here that this is a
reduction in one direction from cloud
distinct to range query which give an
algorithm for cloud listing in the paper
we also show that there are reverse
Direction reductions as well from range
queries to Cloud distinct but we will
not be discussing it in this top
okay so that's the cumulative Cloud
listing problem let us now go back here
and talk about the next setting the
fixed window setting
and this is a new reduction that we give
here
as I said earlier we are giving a
reduction from this setting to range
query on domain size W where the view is
the window size
but for Simplicity here I will present
the reduction where the domain size is T
instead which is a weaker reduction
there is a simple trick that can reduce
the domain size from T to the bill but I
would not be representing it here
okay so let's focus at this reduction
from fixed window queries to range query
on domain size t
again the goals are pretty similar to
before we want the neighbor preserving
relationship to get DP and we want the
correctness where now the correctness
means that for each fixed window call
distinct query on X we should be able to
answer it using a range query on y
so how do we do this
so the reaction works as follows
again we'll create vector v i for each x
i
roughly speaking we won the vector we I
to encode the difference between
consecutive physics window called this
thing but on only the x i element alone
what this mean more formally is that the
J coordinate of v i
is equals to
whether I occurs in the window from J to
J plus the blue minus 1.
minus whether I occurs in time
J minus 1 to J plus W minus 2 or in
other words the difference between the
answer in the current window and the
previous window
just to give you a more concrete example
let's consider W equals to 2 here and
let's consider item one
to fill in the first coordinate of V1
we take a look at whether this item 1
occurs in the current window
and the answer is yes it does it occurs
in the second time step
and then we subtract from it
whether
this item one occurs in the previous
time window and in this case it doesn't
occur in the previous time window
so we want would be equals to plus one
next me we move on to the second
coordinate of V1
and in this case we would look at
these two times windows and since the
item 1 occur in both time Windows the
answer for this coordinate would be zero
next again we move on to the third
coordinate of V1 and now we look at
these two uh windows
in the second window
the element doesn't occur whereas in the
previous time window the element occurs
so here we are putting in -1
and we continue doing this for the rest
of the V I's
now once we have constructed this
structure when we want to Output a fixed
window query from day to day plus W
minus one we simply asked for a range
query from 1 to J on y
and it is not hard to see that since we
set each VI to be subtraction of the
answer of consecutive queries
all the middle terms cancel out and we
are left indeed with the fixed window
query answer for j2j plus W minus 1 when
we ask for range query on y from 1 to J
so the correctness holds
for the neighbor preserving relationship
we will not show the full proof here but
the rough idea is that if we make a
single event level change then it will
only affect the plus one and -1 in VI
that is immediately before and after it
and it will leave all the other
coordinates alone
this means that it will affect only a
constant number of bis which in turn
mean that it only affect a constant
number of Y by a constant amount so we
satisfy the neighbor preserving
relationship as well
so that's a rough sketch for this
reduction from
fixed window called this thing to one
dimensional range query which give us
the First new algorithm in our paper
all right so that's all the time that I
have to discuss the technical
contributions of our paper so let me
quickly conclude here
in the paper we consider many different
setting of cloud listing and K occurring
items in time windows and the different
settings include different neighboring
relationships such as item level VPN
even level DP we consider the three
different query families including the
cumulative time window and fixed window
today we only present the result about
prdp but in the paper we also consider
the approximate DP case where Delta is
greater than 0 as well
we also consider uh the difference
between bundle and single time setting
the one I presented today is the bundle
setting in the paper we also consider
this single done setting which means
that in each time step
at most one element is contributed
across all the items
all the bounds that we derive in our
paper are tied to within a poly
logarithmic factor in the time Horizon
and polynomial in K factors in some
cases this polynomial in K factors are
not tight and in all cases we only get
additive factors in the lower bound
whereas in the upper bound they are
usually multiplicative so it remains an
interesting question to close this Gap
another interesting aspect of the
problem which we haven't discussed today
is with regards to the streaming setting
in a streaming setting we have to answer
all the queries that we can answer
immediately after we receive the input
for time step J
it turns out that uh most of the range
query algorithms including the binary
tree mechanism that we discussed earlier
already works in the streaming setting
so our algorithm which proceed by
reduction to range queries also work in
this streaming setting as well
but the downside here is that we require
memory that is linear in the number of
items there have been several previous
works that try to get this memory
reduce and it it remains an interesting
question to get the Thai privacy utility
and memory trade-off for this setting
and with that uh thank you all very much
for your attention thank you